hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 1
episode 3 Lord snow the episode in which
Ned Stark arrives at King's Landing and
pisses off everyone while Jon does the
same at the wall and we had fascinating
introductions to some of the best
characters of the series and although
this is one of the only episodes of Game
of Thrones with 0 deaths it does give us
this satisfying shut up of Varys I don't
take orders from savages or their [ __ ]
do you hear me if you're new to this
series I'm rewatching every episode of
Game of Thrones in the first season
analyzing the admissible ways these old
episodes foreshadow and connect the
later seasons that this channel was
already broken down now I would say
episode 3 is the first episode of the
series to truly diverge from the isang
of Ice and Fire books many of these
scenes were original creations for the
show so what was changed well in the
books there is actually no version of
the scene that we see in the opening
minutes an episode between Ned and Jamie
at the foot of the Iron Throne one of my
favorite moments of the whole series and
even though it's not in the book it does
reference many things from the literary
backstory must be strange for you coming
into this room now of course Jamie's
referring to this being the location of
the killing of Ned's father and brother
but this also alludes to their past
standoff during the sack of King's
Landing when Ned arrived with a red cape
he famously found the Kingslayer having
just killed the Mad King sitting on the
Iron Throne and he stared him down until
he got off the throne so this time
Jamie's sitting on the steps echoes this
past tension lets you see you're
protecting the throne now another scene
not in the books is this one between
Cersei and Joffrey notice Joffrey's line
here you're a warrior like your father
I'm not like him I didn't fight off
anything it bit me and all I did was
scream huh now this is a small moment
but it's really the only time I can
remember Joffrey appearing at all
likeable an actual human being who I
almost feel sympathy for now no not
gonna happen can we roll the clip again
still it's interesting that Cersei
distorts the truth corrupting her son it
has seen a false version of the world so
really this scene is reframing Joffrey
as less of a born this way monster and
more of a victim of his mother's
psychotic worldview we saw another
adapted parent-child moment between Ned
and Arya but in this case they left
something out from the books the books
Ned shares this poetic insight when the
snows fall and the white winds blow the
lone
dies but the pack survives no no maybe
the writers felt this metaphor was too
flowery for Ned on the show but it
becomes a key concept that keeps coming
back to the book version of Aria again
and again in their journey later on she
judges this lesson cynically realizing
that in her case the lone wolf actually
survived another book reference came
from old nan and bran I could tell you
about ser Duncan the tall those were
always your favorites well in the book
sir Duncan the tall was a hedge Knight
and the subject of George RR Martin's
three Duncan AG novellas by the way the
egg of that story was to Squire the
young Prince Aegon Targaryen later egg
on the fifth grandfather to the Mad King
dunk actually visited Winterfell in one
of his adventures and it's believed he
met old man and her youth nice this
episode also gives us another twist in
the mystery of who owns a Valyrian steel
cat's paw dagger Littlefinger lies
saying that he lost it in a bet to
Tyrion in order to frame Tyrion and
start a conflict between the Starks and
Lannisters in the books this mystery is
wrapped up more discreetly in later
books as Tyrion and Jaime each to do
said Joffrey must have stolen the dagger
from Robert's armory and hired the
assassin in order to impress his father
which yeah it was kind of weird so I was
actually happy with how the show gave
this dagger more of a smoking gun
relevance in later seasons other non
book scenes written for the show
included this one with Cersei and Jaime
and a later on with Jorah Rakharo and
Eyrie and while some of these scenes
were just added to pad out episodes
screen times some of the best writing on
Game of Thrones came from these scenes
the one that comes to my mind was this
one with Robert drunkenly recalling
first kills along with Barristan Selmy
and Jaime notice Mark Addy's impressive
tonal shift from near regret to killing
Charlie boy to rage at his current life
he could have lingered a ledge of the
battle with the smart boys and today his
wife would be making him miserable his
sons would be ingrates and he'd be
waking three times in the night to piss
into a bowl wine oh so great this
reveals Roberts inner desire for a
climactic Laureus death on a battlefield
like the one he delivered Rhaegar
Targaryen as opposed to his current slow
march to death as he grows old on a
throne also in the scene Jamie gives us
this key reveal of the mad Kings final
words he said the same thing
you've been saying for hours burn them
all this foreshadows Jamie opening up
about this moment in season 3 defending
his choice as a heroic one got them all
bendy commanded you to kill your own
father before I spoil too much of future
episodes of this show because apparently
some of you are watching this series for
the first time I'll let you skip to this
time to avoid any more discussion of
later episodes peace for the rest of you
guys let's dive into these sneaky
foreshadowing moments in our segment
okay so back in that scene was Cersei
and Joffrey she tells her son this
everyone who isn't us is an enemy these
words define Cersei as a shrewd yet
paranoid tactician and they echo
recently with Jaime in season 7 enemies
everywhere was surrounded by traitors we
also get a clever glimpse at arias
murder his future in the immediate next
shot with arias stabbing the dinner
table practicing she says for Joffrey
notice how in all the scenes that arias
speaks in this episode she's holding a
different weapon and then coming back to
this net an aria moment in hindsight
this starts six together idea comes full
circle in the recent season 7 finale
with Sansa quoting the exact dialogue
that Ned spoke in the book father
the snows fall and the white winds blow
the lone wolf dies but the pact survives
I also have this line from old man oh
don't listen to it at all lies
Colleen a crow a liar is for one
hilarious but also it foreshadows brands
doubt toward the messages of the
three-eyed Raven who is called a
three-eyed crow in the books let's face
it this old crows words are definitely
manipulative and deceptive in their
vagueness like he tells brand that he
will fly but will he literally fly Oh No
maybe old Dan was right here that bran
shouldn't take literally the words of
old men who live in trees and notice
Rob's skepticism here sometimes she told
me the sky is blue because we live
inside the eye of
giant named Macomber now there could be
a connection here to one of the opening
shots of season seven when a giant white
and the army of the Dead march toward
bran with his big blue eye coming into
that close-up
either way this vision is exactly the
ghost story old man warned bran about
come to life Rob joking about it here
signals that he is not really prepared
for that winter another parallel here
notice how Ned thanks Littlefinger for
bringing him to his wife beautiful this
same chokeslam will be repeated against
Littlefinger by John when Littlefinger
bringing some Catelyn in season seven I
love sunshine as I left her mother
actually this parallel between Ned and
John is happening all over this episode
and I'll get to the deeper meaning of
that later then notice what Jaime says
to Cersei if he does I'll kill him and
let's stop the kingdoms Amy's whole it's
the two of us against world baby
philosophy will actually come back to
haunt him in season seven when Cersei
uses this philosophy as a rationale to
forget about their dead kids at a
stakeout and the fact that this now
disgusts Jaime just shows how much his
characters changed over this series
there's another more subtle connection
to Season seven from vengeance start you
know a brother once told me that nothing
someone says before the word but really
counts like the pack survives quote we
never really hear ned actually say this
but john also quotes this to Sansa in
the season 7 premiere they respect you
they really do but you have to
why you nothing did father used to say
everything before the word both is
horseshit and later notice the pike
choreography of arias sparring with
Syrio Forel these lunges imposes
parallel Arya's later sparring with
Brienne and Winterfell in the middle
season seven with Brienne doing the same
two-handed night stance and Aria doing
the one-handed water dance and there's
this haunting line from Maester Aemon
like winter does come God's help us all
if we're not already
notice how the editing immediately cuts
to a shot of Danny's three dragon eggs
with Vaziri on-screen color two egg
front and center now I'm not sure if
this is intentional or not because who
knows if any often Weiss intended on the
resurrected Missouri on written by the
night king being the one to torch the
wall but it's a fun connection to think
about also this ghost story warning from
Maester Aemon is parallel to the ghost
story we heard from the other elderly
figure of this episode old man let's
actually go through all the other
interesting continuity parallels and
callbacks in this episode in our segment
callbacks
okay so early in this episode Ned gives
his daughter Sansa a doll and surely
she's a huge [ __ ] about it and wines
that she hasn't played with doll since
she was 8 but I think this gift
parallels the one Catelyn made for bran
in Episode two you know the one made out
of twigs and garbage in both cases these
stark parents are futilely attempting to
comfort their children with handmade
toys and are really useful to them as
well meaning as these parental figures
are they don't really know what their
children need later in the episode Dany
discusses Dothraki slavery with Jorah
hinting that she finds a practice
barbaric this is a callback to Viserys
at the beginning of episode 2 who told
Jorah that he considered Westeros his
ban on slavery nonsense and in my reign
you haven't punished for such nonsense
so notice that we're already seeing the
contrast in compassion between these two
Targaryen siblings and then Tyrians
goodbye to John at the wall includes
this great callback with theory and
fulfilling a promise he made to his
niece and nephew last episode no I just
want to stand on top of the wall and
piss off the edge of the world okay
let's move on to some of the subtle
sound and music choices in this episode
in our section here that okay when Ned
meets Arya in her chamber listen closely
to the noise that we hear in the back
ah hear that the chimes in the
background our church bells coming from
the Sept of Baelor those same bells toll
later this season signaling to Aria that
her father's trial is about to begin
so the bells here in this scene
foreshadow Ned state now this episode
uses a similar device again later but
first I want to talk about some key
music cues we talked about how Ned's
talk with Aria is a key stark pact
survives moment and composer Ramin
Djawadi emphasizes that by playing the
stark theme here from the butcher's boy
I hate them then immediately after this
old man's ghost story is totally
terrifying but a big part of that is the
return of gelotti's white Walker theme
mixed in quietly under her words
thousands of years ago that came a night
that lasted a generation Kings froze to
death in their castles same as the
Shepherd's in their huts and women
smothered their babies rather than see
them starve but coming back to this
foreshadowing with Ned listening closely
to the closing shots of the episode
[Music]
yes Ned begins to hear the clacking of
the wooden swords as the clangs of metal
swords and when Serio gently pokes arya
the sound of flesh impale for ned this
is another example of winter is coming
he knows that before long this swordplay
will transform from a game to a matter
of life and death and before I get to
the deeper meaning of all this there
were a few other details of this episode
that I notice - the background so let's
go over them in our segment zoom in
enhance okay back in that opening scene
in the red keep let's zoom and enhance
on the window behind the Iron Throne
notice how in season 1 the window
doesn't contain the red seven-pointed
star that a dozen later seasons instead
it's a stained-glass depiction of a stag
the symbol of house Baratheon this image
reflects Robert's reign he wasn't much
of a religious man in fact his rebellion
and usurping to the Iron Throne went
against the religious authority who
sanctioned the Targaryen is the rightful
monarchs now later in the series
Joffrey's reign will be accompanied by
the installation of a seven-pointed star
window representing Circe's attempt to
use that divine authority to legitimize
her son but of course later on after
Cersei struggles with the faith she'll
replace that star with her own Lannister
lion in the next scene let's look at
Robert's royal decree for an expensive
tournament Ned reads off these expenses
two thousand go dragons to the champion
20,000 to the runner-up 20,000 to the
winning Archer pycelle adds up to 80,000
and ask Littlefinger if the crown can
bear the cost but zoom and enhance on
that scroll look at the bottom there Ned
lifts up another 20,000 gold dragons for
combat with swords and clubs so the
total cost should be one hundred
thousand why doesn't it leave off this
last line item my guess is Ned never
even considered this costly tourney a
real possibility him going through all
these details would just be a waste of
time this is yet another example of
Ned's naivete coming in as hand of the
king leave this episode notice the
Dothraki word that Dany is trying to
pronounce at chucka Oh chucka Oh chucka
in Dothraki
at jakar translates to pride the term is
derived from the Daath word to hawk the
name of the long braid worn by Dothraki
warriors that they only cut if they ever
lose and
it's a physical symbol of their pride
and look closely at what Daenerys is
doing here she's having her hair braided
forming her own jihad and this happens
right after she won her first victory
deflating the pride of her cruel brother
Viserys one of my favorite miscible
details from the whole series is that
Danny's jayhawk season after season
becomes longer and more complex and it
all starts in this moment okay let's
move on to the deeper meaning of this
episode Daenerys is successfully
adapting to her surroundings but she's
not the only one to go through that kind
of transition this episode the title
Lord snow is actually taken from a
character we haven't really talked about
in this video yet Jon Snow
well it's know he is you're the least
useless person the Lord snow is of
course thorns Maquis nickname for John a
proud new comer who's too frosty to make
allies he talks down to and alienates
all of his fellow Knights watch recruits
immediately but as I said before this
episode is comparing John to another
Lord snow Ned Stark and his first few
minutes of arriving in the capital Ned
immediately dismisses various he mocks
Littlefinger to losing to his brother
Brandon and the duel and he implies that
pycelle is disloyal come on Ned that's
way too frosty in the books Littlefinger
actually calls out Ned's icy demeanor
joking that Starks are made of ice and
melt below the neck and Ned coolly
responds that he doesn't plan on melting
anytime soon and then in this episode
Littlefinger sums up the Starks with
this line
and I like how the editing immediately
jumps to the other Lord snow after this
line even though Jon and Ned are both
frosty men bitter over being misled into
coming to this rotten dead-end John
after heating the wisdom of Benjamin
Tyrion learns to adapt to his new
surroundings by the end of the episode
he helps his brothers rather than
talking down to them and beating the
crap out of him making more enemies than
allies will always be a struggle for Jon
throughout the series but he at least
makes the right friends for Ned on the
other hand stubbornness is his tragic
flaw and his honorable refusal to play
this game Thrones will lead him to die
as Lord snow a question for you guys do
you think this scenes not in the book
and proved the writing on the show or do
you think the show really needs George
RR Martin's dialogue comments down below
and tweet me your thoughts directly at
EA boss or follow new rockstars on
Twitter at new rockstars for updates on
our videos now if you like thinking
deeply about your favorite shows like I
do and impressing your friends with how
smart you are another channel besides
one that I can't recommend enough is
wisecrack specifically their quick take
series is great
Jared's video on the philosophy of
Westworld in a way it uses music to tell
a story is exactly the kind of
thoughtful video essay we aim to do here
definitely give it a watch and subscribe
to wisecrack by clicking the link in the
description below and yeah I subscribe
to us here at new rock stars for more
Game of Thrones analysis I'm gonna try
to keep making these season when we
watch videos no promises on release
schedule because we cover a lot here but
you can help by liking and sharing this
video around and by contributing to us
on patreon big thanks to all of our
current donors especially Laurie Denning
right thanks for watching bye